welcome back to m coding i'm james
murphy
if you had to pick what would you say is
your most disliked dunder method in
python
maybe dunder new and all of the meta
class glory that goes with that
or maybe you've seen my video about plus
equals and don't like the in-place
methods
or hey nobody likes taking the time to
write a wrapper maybe that's it
well i've got a different choice one
that's so disliked in the python
community that if you so much as ask
what it does on stack overflow you will
be inundated with comments telling you
not to use it
what dunder is it that could possibly
harbor this much hate it's none other
than dunder dell
so in this video let's check out
dunderdell see what it's supposed to do
hone in on some of those pitfalls and of
course see some more robust alternatives
at the end
first up how does dunderdell relate to
the dell keyword well there's three ways
that you can use the dell keyword you
can say del x brackets something and
that usage corresponds exactly to
calling the dunder del item method
you can call it with dell x dot
something and that corresponds exactly
to the dunder del adder method finally
there's just del x
which does not call the dunder del
method this is our first hint about why
people don't like dell
dell item and dell adder are very
straightforward nobody hates those stir
x caused under stir
wrapper x caused under wrapper len x
calls under len but del x does not
called under del but it kind of looks
like it does if i run this example i see
the dunder del print out but if i
comment out del x it still gets called
let's throw in some print statements at
the start just before we call dell and
at the end so we see exactly when this
dunder dial is being called
we see start then just before dell then
the dell printout and then end so it
seems like dell is triggering dunder
dell
when we comment out dunderdell it
appears that it's getting called after
the end of the function
so is this like manual versus explicit
garbage collection
well still no if we create another
variable y and assign it to x then even
if we manually delete x we don't see the
dunder del until after the end of the
function
dunder del is of course short for delete
this function is supposed to run before
the object is deleted but there's a big
difference between the object itself and
the name that you assigned to it
every object in python has what's called
a reference count the reference count
tells you how many things are
referencing that object assigning a name
like x to point to an object increases
its reference count if i create another
name like y for the same object that
also increases the reference count so
what the dell keyword is doing here is
actually just deleting the name x this
effectively just reduces the reference
count of the object by one but we don't
want to delete the object if there are
still things referencing it so dunder
del is actually supposed to be run when
the object's ref count hits zero if we
didn't have the y variable then del x
here deletes the only reference to the
object so its ref count goes to zero and
it should be deleted
that's why dell sometimes calls dunder
dell but that's kind of just
circumstantial but even once you
understand the dell x doesn't directly
call dunderdale there's still a lot of
confusion around under dell you might
think that dunder del is a great place
to put cleanup code maybe i open up a
file descriptor and then when nobody's
using it anymore close it the main
problem with this idea is that the
documentation for dunderdell explicitly
states that it may just never be called
not a great property for cleanup code
the first reason the dell may never be
called is because of reference cycles
suppose i have an x and a y maybe it's a
tree structure so x has some children
and y is one of them then i include a
back reference to x as the parent of y
so x's children has a reference to y
and then y has a reference back up to x
this is called a reference cycle and
when you have a reference cycle it's
impossible for either of the ref counts
of x or y to hit zero even after this
function returns and it's impossible to
access x or y ever again because they
were just local variables their ref
counts won't go to zero because they're
still referencing each other furthermore
even if an object's ref count hits zero
python explicitly states that that
doesn't guarantee the object's dell is
called at that time
now in c python which is the python that
99 of you are going to be using see
python does call dell immediately when
the ref count hits zero and for
reference cycles there's a garbage
collector which periodically runs and
detects these kinds of cycles as long as
the interpreter didn't flat out crash
see python does a really good job of
ensuring that the garbage collector runs
and all of your objects dell methods are
called but still the docs insist that
this might not happen so you can't
really depend on it oh and by the way
since the time that a dell is called
isn't guaranteed it's basically
impossible for you to be able to handle
any errors that might propagate out of
them therefore the interpreter just
completely ignores exceptions raised in
a dell method
it'll still print the trace back but as
you can see it still ran the code
afterwards
oh yeah and remember if dell is called
at all it might be called while the
interpreter is shutting down this dell
tries to dump some state into a json
file remember exceptions get ignored if
anything goes wrong trying to open this
file and then if python happens to wait
until the interpreter is shutting down
to call this dell then this json module
which is a global variable may have
already been deleted in c python in
practice using even a relatively oldish
version like 37 i haven't actually run
into this issue but once again the
documentation won't make any promises
and says you need to watch out for this
what else could there possibly be that's
more confusing about dell
with all the lack of promises about even
basic functionality you wouldn't think
dell would support that many features
but it actually purposefully supports
the idea of so-called resurrecting an
object that's about to be deleted
let's say this del meth is called
because there are no more outside
accessible references to the self
variable well we can just put self into
a global variable thereby increasing its
reference count back up to 1. of course
it's kind of your own fault if you do
something like this but python
guarantees you are allowed to do this if
you increase the ref count of an object
inside dell then its memory won't be
reclaimed by the garbage collector it
will survive until another day but you
know they're not letting you get away
without throwing another curveball in
there right if an object is resurrected
then when it dies again its dell method
may be called or it might not be called
so you also need to make sure that your
dell doesn't do anything nasty if it
gets called twice i already mentioned
that exceptions from dell get ignored
right okay so how about we just get to
an example where it does something
useful and it should theoretically be
okay to use
this class makes a temporary directory
when you create an instance it creates
an actual temp file
you can manually call remove on it or
the file is removed when it's garbage
collected notice that the first time we
call remove it sets name to none this
means that if remove is called multiple
times either by the user or by dell
being called multiple times nothing will
happen after the first time we're
definitely depending here on see
python's unadvertised property that
garbage collection will happen before
shutdown and it will happen early enough
in shutdown that this module shell util
will still exist i'm definitely not
confident given all those restrictions
but it does seem to work with the
current version of python that i'm using
so if dell is so finicky it might never
get called it might get called twice it
ignores exceptions globals might no
longer exist how am i supposed to
reliably clean up the resources used in
my code
the most robust solution is to use a
with statement define enter and exit
methods and make sure that you call your
cleanup code in the exit method
then you can use the class like this we
just say with we create a new instance
as d do whatever we need to do inside
the width block then when the width
block is over python guarantees that the
remove method is called the behavior of
the with statement is much more
precisely defined and you can depend on
it this is slightly limiting though we
have to use the with statement what if i
don't know when i want to delete my temp
file maybe i'm making a text editor and
i want to delete this temp file whenever
the user is not looking at it anymore
that might not be confinable to a width
block but certainly if python has no
more references to the object then it's
fine to delete if you really want to
support cases where you can't use with
statements there is another alternative
let's leave our enter and exit method we
still want to encourage people to do it
the right way go ahead and delete the
dunder dowel then use the weak ref
module to create a finalizer for our
object we can manually call the
finalizer in our remove method it's even
fine to call it multiple times we can
also check if a finalizer has already
run by checking its alive property a
finalizer does have some of the same
pitfalls as dell in particular they have
the same exception ignoring behavior
however python makes much stronger
guarantees that finalizers will run and
when they'll run
in particular when the interpreter shuts
down all remaining finalizers that are
still alive and haven't been disabled
will be called and they'll be called in
the reverse order that they were created
in it's also guaranteed that these
finalizers will run early in the
shutdown process before any global
variables like modules have been deleted
and of course by design finalizers are
allowed to be called multiple times and
their effects will only happen the first
time they're called this makes them a
more robust and dependable solution
compared to dell when you can't use a
with statement
i didn't really say much about what weak
references are
normal references like assigning the
name x to a variable increase the
reference count those are called strong
references and they would keep the
object from being garbage collected but
we obviously don't want the finalizer of
our object to keep it from being garbage
collected its whole purpose is to run
right before the object is garbage
collected so it's actually possible to
create so-called weak references that
don't increase the reference count and
don't prevent it from being garbage
collected if you want to hear more about
them make sure to leave a comment that's
all i've got see you in the next one and
don't forget to slap that like button an
odd number of times